hey little guys my name is the chana so
I was just sitting here working on hazel
specifically the hazel development
branch and I thought that it would be a
cool idea to just kind of show you guys
what I'm up to
Pacifica I'm working through this kind
of issue that I have here and I thought
that instead of just working through it
all by myself in my little office I
would kind of just film myself working
through this issue and show you I
believe the outcome and me actually
solving it so if those of you who don't
know the hazel development branch is a
version of the game engine series a
version of hazel where I've basically
done a whole lot of work because the way
that I kind of make the game engine
series is that while whilst I do pretty
much film a video every week and I plan
that video and I do all the stuff kind
of required to write code for that
specific video obviously in my mind like
I need to be well ahead of my videos in
in hazel right so it's an edit because
of two reasons first of all I mean I
need to know where the series is going
it would be kind of very short-sighted I
guess of me to just plan for like the
next few episodes without kind of seeing
the big picture but also it's kind of
important to me to also make sure that
I'm actually leading that the
development of hazel somewhere like into
like a successful place right I can't
just kind of be like oh yeah eventually
we'll add this stuff and in my mind I'm
like well I hope I know how to do that
or I hope that's gonna work out in the
end that would kind of be let's just say
that wouldn't be ideal so what I do in
my spare time is I just work on this
game engine called hazel and I kind of
just work on this version of hazel
whenever I kind of feel like it whenever
I want to as much as I can really
and I've developed it a lot a lot more
kind of past the point where we're up to
in the game engine series so that
essentially I know where that game
engine series where where all of those
videos are heading so for example and
I'll show you a little bit of the hazel
to up and brush here as well but
basically like I've got you know full
PPR kind of scene I've got animation
I've got like a bit of like an editor
where you can like well it's more of a
viewer wake and like load all of your
different textures and any model file
and display that stuff buy a lot play
around with the lighting setup that kind
of stuff so I've developed a quite a bit
and if you do want to access to that you
can actually get access to that
just straight away by going a patient on
home for slash the Cherno pledging there
apart from just getting access just
supports this channel a lot so thank you
obviously to all the page ones that make
it to cut this kind of stuff possible
because I wouldn't be sitting here
working on hazel and working on all
these amazing videos for you guys if it
wasn't for those people supporting me on
patreon so those people doing that
seriously like the other people that
make this stuff possible I'm so thankful
for that so anyway this problem that
I've got let's take a look if we just
boot up cable here so we've got the
hazel engine here this is probably the
first time for a lot of you guys seeing
and so I'll give you a little bit of a
tour what we have here is basically two
different ways of viewing things right
now we've got model and spheres and this
kind of whole section here by the way is
like the kind of I guess level editor
sort of kind of section I mean right now
it's obviously just like a set of maybe
I'll put this over here to make it a
little bit better it's basically just a
bunch of environment settings that we
have here as well as this kind of model
stuff which lets us come pick a mesh
that we want to render pick albedo
normals metalness roughness that kind of
stuff we can even dynamically reload
certain shaders and do stuff like that
which is pretty cool
I'm and very useful of course for
development is that we can play around
with like the light color here and you
can see that there and in fact
everything here is oh and we can play
with like the exposure because you can
see this looks a little bit overexposed
because the light is very bright but
luckily we're in an HDR pipeline so we
can just dyed that down and you can see
we get all the detail back if we just
simply lower the exposure anyway so we
have this kind of scene and what I'm the
primary purpose of this scene was to
test physically based rendering of
course and I mean like it looks pretty
bad in certain cases that's just because
when I'm filtering if I actually turn on
radiance pre-filtering properly you can
see that it works correctly but it takes
like a long time you can see what the
lag is like here it's a bit crazy that's
just because we're doing it live whereas
usually you would actually bake it into
the cube map mid levels which is
something that I definitely have on my
to-do list but anyway we had this kind
of baby aisle scene which is lovely but
in adding animation which is what we see
here I noticed that well the reflection
isn't really working correct
it's quite weird and that's interesting
because they're basically I mean right
now they're two separate shaders because
they need to be but in the beginning
they were two that like the shaders were
identical so why is it working here and
why is it not working here especially
because like the fragment shader doesn't
need to change so there are a few issues
that that could cause this specifically
the reason that it might not work for
animation and if we kind of just let me
just bring up that we've got mesh debug
here as well let me just bring that up
here and just pause this animation might
just break this off and pop it here so
we can we can scrub through the
animation here and I'll actually just
drop the roughness down so that it's
super reflective so we can see
everything so that's reflecting the sky
it looks like although it's where that
it's kind of solid blue if we kind of
scrub through this you can see that as
weak as the gun kind of rotates up so
does the environment map right so
straight away just by looking at this I
can kind of tell that the reason that's
happening right look at that it's just
rotating with it it's almost certainly
because the way that this animation is
skeletal animation which means that what
we have here is a bunch of bones and in
the shader specifically we're getting
the information about the bones and
we're applying the the kind of the
transformation matrices from each bone
to the appropriate vertices based on
like the vertices that that bone
actually affects and the weights and all
of that stuff so that's how it's being
kind of animated right that's happening
in the vertex shader so as it's being
animated we have that transformation
matrix but it looks like we're just not
actually sending any information about
that burn transform to the to the
fragment shader at all because again
like when when it comes time to
calculate like the view vector from the
camera to the normal and like that we
can reflect it properly in sample from
the cube map it looks like we're just
not
we're not factoring in that that bone
transformation at all and if we actually
look at the slide go back there's
actually quite a good example for look
at the slide go back it's hard to see
because it's so I'm just completely blue
she's very interesting but if you look
at the slide go back which happens here
and we can actually even play this in
super slo-mo you can see that it's not
that slide isn't like it it's just
completely painted on like this is
actually a good place I think to look at
it same that's completely not changing
so it looks like both the translation
and the rotation none of that's being
applied so we definitely need to take a
look at the shader and see what the
problem is so here we have the animation
shader that were being that's being used
and really all we need to look at is the
vertex shader I think because I mean if
we look at the fragment shader
specifically at a part of it that does
all of this stuff you can see the view
vector here is calculated by using the
world position and then also we're
definitely using normals in a lot of
places to actually you know calculate I
guess the reflection vector and certain
other things that we need to actually
light I guess the model using IBL which
is image image based lighting which is
where that kind of cube map plays a part
so if we take a look at this yeah so it
looks like our world position and normal
world normals are being multiplied by
the model matrix which is correct but
looks like this normal is just
completely being left alone which is
interesting by normal is also being left
alone this is all fine and then well
position as well which we do use again
that's just that's taking into account
the model matrix which is correct right
normal should also take into account the
model matrix that's all that it isn't
because if we rotate our sphere for
example the normals aren't gonna be
rotated with it so that's actually one
thing we should fix it's kind of hard to
demonstrate here but that's just
something additional that I've just
bought it and then also both of both the
world position normal by normal and the
world normal to probably find the way
they are I don't think I'm not even sure
what we really use them for so we use
them if we're using a normal texture but
that should be okay I think so what we
really need to do is I think for this
problem especially we should make sure
that we're taking this bone transform
and for world position we need
both the translation and rotation of
course there's a world position so we'll
make sure that we just multiply that as
a mat for however for normals we don't
need the translation back we don't want
the translations so we can just cast
this to a map three when we multiply it
and that will of course only essentially
multiply translate a rotation and scale
and rotation specifically what we're
looking for we shouldn't have any well
scale matrices should be fine as well
the same thing needs to happen to our
binomials as well and that looks pretty
good now world normals does the not take
into account the byrne matrix but based
on the usage I don't I don't think I
want to touch that yet just because I
think that that might not be something
that we need to necessarily touch anyway
we're not using any normal map here
anyway for this example so we've got
world position normal and by normal
that's being multiplied in let's see if
that made any difference I'm pretty sure
that that would fix our problem and okay
look at that so it looks completely
different now I'm if I just kind of zoom
in here it looks completely different
let's see if it looks right so what I'll
do again is I will pause the animation
I'll dial the roughness down all the way
okay we're actually reflecting stuff
which is pretty cool let's see if when
the slide moves back if the reflection
stays static and it does rise so you can
see that slide is moving back here but
the reflection staying the way that it
should be which i think is pretty cool
and then finally the rotation is the
other thing that kind of interested me
so that rotation looks fine so if we
look at it yeah there you can see the
reflection is kind of moving because
we're rotating and then finally that gun
being shot as well looks like that's
working correctly so if we just go and
let's just play this in like really slow
motion and see what this looks like
alright that looks pretty good and we
can float the bullet here the bullet is
rotating and the reflection looks pretty
good to me
okay cool alright and then if we look at
our spheres they look correct also so
that was just quite a simple problem
that just had to do with making sure
that once we added animation all those
bone transformations we also applied
them to the world position and
the normals okay so hope you guys
enjoyed this little video let me know
what you think and if you want to see
more of this kind of stuff in the future
because this is quite fun to make and as
I'm kind of working here it's nice to
almost have a bit of a development like
I guess I'm just showing you guys what
I'm up to any kind of problems that I'm
working through as well just to kind of
share those with you guys I think it's a
cool idea drop a like below if you
enjoyed this and a comment as well if
you want to see more of this kind of
stuff in the future don't forget to
support this channel on patreon and make
this kind of stuff possible in the
future as well support the development
of hazel and all of my videos thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you in
the next video goodbye
[Music]